le procès carlos touche à sa fin le
verdict est attendu demain ce soir
l'avocat général a requis la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité contre carlos
accusé je vous le rappelle d'avoir tué
trois personnes dont deux policiers de
la dst en juin 75 clément weill-raynal
la réclusion criminelle à perpétuité
requise contre carlos l'avocat général
jean monnet qui a réclamé la peine
maximale contre le terroriste accusé
d'avoir abattu le 27 juin 1975
deux policiers de la dst le réquisitoire
du représentant du ministère public
avait été précédé cet après midi des
plaidoiries des avocats des parties
civiles qui avaient stigmatisé la
lâcheté de l'accusé tout au long du
procès
carlos a refusé d'assumer la
responsabilité de la tuerie de la rue
toullier préférant choisir la voie de l'
esquive du mépris et de l'injure à
l'égard de la cour des jurés et des
familles des victimes à battre des
policiers de son froid qui sont pas
armés ça n'a évidemment rien de glorieux
donc c'est difficile pour lui de
l'accepter par rapport à l'image qu'il a
lui-même et qu'il veut donner au monde à
savoir à savoir celui d'un
révolutionnaire professionnel d'un
combattant d'un soldat
or ça c'est pas l'action de soldats
malgré les multiples provocations de la
défense carlos n'aura finalement pas
réussi à déstabiliser l'accusation après
huit jours d'audience le procès touche
maintenant à sa fin
le verdict devrait être rendu demain
dans la soirée